so that
resistance the attack involved killing a
large number of Israeli
civilians there's many questions asked
there but one is do you think Hamas
fully understood what the retaliation
will involve from Israel into Gaza they
had to understand I
mean you had you know operation cast LED
in
200 uh 8 2009 it started I think right
after Christmas 2008 and it ended right
before President Obama took office uh in
January 2009 and
uh the Israelis periodically do what
they call mowing the lawn where they go
into Gaza and they pound the
Palestinians uh to remind them that
they're not supposed to rise up and
cause any problem uh
so there's no question in my mind that
the uh the Hamas forces understood full
well that the Israelis would retaliate
and they would retaliate in for us as
they have done yeah even the metaphor of
mowing the lawn is disturbing to me in
many
ways I actually
saw uh Norman filastine I think say that
well then if you use that metaphor then
you could say that Hamas was also mowing
the lawn it's such a
horrific image because the result on
either side is just the death of
civilians